There are so many mutations and so many causes for mutations it's crazy.
>> it's true, and we haven't even had time to cover sequence
inversions, jumping genes. Or cosmic rays
and how other chemicals cause mutations too.
>> Why don't we just stick to what happens to the mutations when we
have them and why is it that some mutations get passed down but others don't?
>> Well, let's think about this in a large population. There
are many mutations or alleles that can persist. But the only way
they can persist over time is if
they get passed down from generation to generation.
>> So reproduction is a selection point?
>> Exactly. It all hinges on reproduction. If you can't make it
to reproductive age, then those alleles
or mutations aren't going to get passed down.
>> So, I've heard this term a lot and I'm sure
you have too, but it reminds me of survival of the fittest.
>> I have heard survival of the fittest is actually a
misnomer in biology. It's one of the most talked about myths.
>> So well, what's inaccurate about it?
>> Well, I would you to figure this
out. Take this scenario, let's imagine we have a
group of about five people out camping together.
Each with different alleles that affect their leg muscles
strength and ability to run. And suddenly, a
hungry bear attacks the camp to eat one of
the campers and they scatter. You tell me,
how fast do you have to run to survive?